[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ciao mi chiamo Cecilia e non sento Luca
da due giorni perché
Ovviamente io
perché è venuta a prendermi in stazione
coperto da un mantello nero mi ha
sorpreso alle spalle dicendo è giunta la
tua ora e io gli ho detto No è giunta la
tua di ora e ci siamo lasciati
Ciao mi chiamo Marina e non sento Marco
da 14 anni perché
perché è un mese dopo avermi regalato
l'anello mi ha detto che non voleva
nulla di impegnativo
Ciao mi chiamo Lidia e non sento Gianni
da 9 anni perché
perché abbiamo provato un corso di tango
e non ci riusciva abbiamo provato il
valzer e mi pestava i piedi anche col
buchi non ci capivamo Allora ho pensato
che se non sa ballare in coppia non sa
vivere neanche in due
ballava bene da solo
Ciao mi chiamo Micaela e non sento
Giuseppe da tre anni perché
perché la vita ha un disegno preciso che
capisci solo col tempo fa entrare e
uscire le persone con un tempismo
perfetto Solo per indicarci la strada
Chi di voi ha mai avuto un ex o una ex
che ridete ovvio che faccio non vi vedo
quindi ci credo
non vedo che non sono l'unico anche se
non lo vedo grazie grazie quindi chi di
voi ha mai avuto un Action
e vedo che non sono l'unico sapete da
chi arrivano queste storie da Gente come
noi gente che ha sofferto
perché una volta passata tipo non lo so
tipo 57 anni Allora una sofferenza
d'amore
ci fa quasi sorridere
Ma quando ci sei dentro dire che ti
cambia l'umore di dire poco
Sfido chiunque a non considerarla una
tragedia
un amore Finito È qualcosa di terribile
sia per chi viene lasciato ma a volte
anche per chi lascia
ora che c'è la luce però evito di
indagare sulle vostre storie
io però ho lasciato e sono stato
lasciato così tante volte da scriverci
un romanzo
prima di scriverlo però ho raccolto un
centinaio di testimonianze che mi hanno
fatto capire una cosa
grazie alle storie degli altri ho
iniziato a fare pace con le mie
poi ho iniziato a fare presentazioni
andare nelle scuole sentirne tante altre
fino a capire un'altra cosa
parlare e ascoltare è qualcosa che
unisce di fronte a un dolore
parlare e ascoltare aiuta a capire se
stessi e gli altri
parlare e ascoltare è un dono per chi
racconta E perché Ascolta
Ecco perché l'unica soluzione a certi
problemi
e fare rete fare rete di fronte a certi
problemi c'è solo una cosa che ci salva
sapete cos'è la condivisione
è proprio la condivisione che rende
sostenibili le difficoltà
a ottobre 2021 ho scoperto di avere
quello che io chiamo un cattivo umore
con la t davanti
ci sta la tossita
un cancro al cervello
Ecco perché ho bisogno di questi
biglietti
perché perdere la memoria ti fa
ricordare di avere un tumore
tumore che secondo gli oncologi anche
dopo l'intervento
al cervello volevo fare la rima
la radioterapia e la chemioterapia
rimarrà per sempre dentro di me
Ammetto che non me l'aspettavo Non me
l'aspettavo credo che nessuno possa
aspettarselo di sicuro lo sentiamo fin
troppe volte dagli altri Ma nessuno si
aspetta almeno io di avere un cancro
invece dopo aver avuto per due mesi
delle allucinazioni un uomo che parlava
è una musica di sottofondo sotto e dopo
essermi ritrovato steso a terra da un
violento attacco pilettico fronte
disanguinata eccetera
ho scoperto di avere quello che
tecnicamente si chiama astrocitoma di
secondo grado
non è stato facile accettare di
svegliarmi in un ospedale con un
braccialetto che non ho scelto io
non è stato facile accettare un
intervento al cervello firmando anche
una liberatoria dove sopra c'era scritto
rischio di morte
non è stato facile indossare una
maschera Azzurra per un mese di
radioterapia
e non è stato facile accettare anche un
anno di chemioterapia
non è stato facile accettare che dei
circa circa
97 98 figli che avrei voluto
non avrei potuto averne neanche uno
ho sbagliato
non è stato facile accettare che prima o
poi il tumore di sicuro tornerà a farsi
vivo
lasciandomi però vivo
tutte nuove esperienze che però mi hanno
insegnato come una cosa brutta insegna
un sacco di cose belle
la prima la cosa più importante della
vita banale come non so cosa sapete
cos'è
anche quelli lì dentro le persone le
persone
qualche giorno fa stavo prendendo un
caffè all'aperto sotto i portici di
Bologna seduto mi passano accanto
camminando al rallentatore due anziani
posso dirlo due anziani Lui ti può frac
Tube farfallino e che camminava molto
lentamente a braccetto con la sua
signora anche lei vestita bene sembrava
che andassero a un matrimonio il loro
non lo so andavano pianissimo E allora
io non tengo più la bocca chiusa ho
iniziato a dire Scusate e loro
Ok ho alzato un po' la voce scusate
e lui tu
ha iniziato leggerissimamente dal ad
accelerare allora A sto punto visto che
con la mia nuova vita Io non ho più
filtri ok Ho iniziato a dire quello che
pensavo urlando siete la coppia più
bella del mondo
lui tu lei tu
si è girato lui si è girata lei sono
venuta al mio tavolino Mi hanno
raccontato di come si sono conosciuti di
come stanno continuando ad avere una
relazione ad amarsi si può dire bene
cosa è successo non è cambiata la vita
di nessuno ma sono stato bene io e sono
stati bene loro
le persone dopo l'intervento I medici mi
hanno caldamente invitato almeno per un
mese a vivere sotto lo stesso tetto con
qualcuno
che vi ridete
prima cosa che ho fatto
Ho chiesto a tutte le mie ex
non ha accettato nessuna
C'è poco da
perciò sapete chi è stata la mia
compagna
come ha detto la mia mamma nel pubblico
la mamma
una donna per dire che una mattina
appena sveglio l'ho trovata in cucina a
condividere il suo stato d'animo così
una donna che ride spesso e volentieri È
Santina non dovrei dire queste cose ma
fa niente che tra le tante cose mi ha
insegnato a vivere la vita sapete come
si capisce
un sorriso che anche senza baffi si
trasforma spesso in risata Allora mia
madre ha diversi tipi di risotto Ok
quella che cerco di ricambiare ogni
giorno perché ormai un anno e mezzo che
vada a pranzo e ai miei genitori e la
risata col cuore Quella che parte da qui
ok E poi sale allora Ve la mostro
tecnicamente la sua
per favore
il sorriso può essere contagioso se
condiviso
parliamo di mio padre L'ho amato
attualmente di fianco a mia madre qui
un uomo per natura meno
risarolo
ridarolo risarò un mix che però il
giorno in cui mi è venuta a prendere in
stazione e in ospedale dopo l'operazione
al cervello
l'ho trovato così
ah dovevo
con la voglia di mettersi in gioco in
tutti i sensi
dopo la scoperta della mia nuova vita
per un po' ho smesso di pubblicare sui
social
però da quando ha iniziato tutti a
scrivermi ma che fine hai fatto in
qualsiasi regione no Se volete tipo
anche marchigiano
ho deciso di iniziare a raccontare la
mia nuova vita sapete come parlando a
modo mio di cose molto profonde ma senza
Mai perdere la leggerezza
il social Per me sono stati una seconda
medicina
ho iniziato a ricevere così tanti
messaggi d'affetto che il mio tumore
Sembrava quasi perdere la t
però ho iniziato a ricevere anche così
tante storie simili o uguali alla mia
che a volte evito proprio di rispondere
lascio direttamente il mio cellulare
la potenza di questo scambio però va
oltre il mio vissuto tante persone
Infatti mi hanno raccontato proprio come
hanno trovato conforto leggendo storie
simili o uguali alle loro
questo perché la condivisione ha fatto
nascere una rete a Maglie così strette
da raggiungere l'obiettivo
difficilissimo
di trasformare
l'insostenibile insostenibile
non ho ancora finito
[Applauso]
Ciao mi chiamo Massimo E non sento il me
stesso di prima dal 13 ottobre 2021
perché mi è servito un cattivo umore con
la t davanti per capire come a volte il
nostro dolore si può condividere con chi
ha voglia di percorrere un tratto di
vita insieme a noi
con un commento in un post sui social
in un pranzo in famiglia
in un reparto d'ospedale
o in un teatro di Modena
[Applauso]